[Musique]
je pense honnêtement que c'est du
sport qui regarde euh il n'y a pas d'
excuse légitime pour des
raisons d'organiser les jeux pendant un
génocide
[Musique]
est-ce que le cio est prêt à assumer
la responsabilité des manifestants
arrêtés à pékin pendant les jeux est-ce que
le cio va continuer  pour réitérer que
la situation des droits de l'homme en chine
n'est pas dans son vestige tout en
affirmant que les droits de l'homme font partie de
la charte olympique,
nous attendons des gouvernements du g7 qu'ils
boycottent les jeux olympiques d'hiver
à pékin
[musique]
c'est en fait à cause des jeux de 2008
à pékin que la situation sur le
terrain au tibet est allée de mal en
pis
je pense que la répression au tibet est en
partie due au fait que la chine a pu accueillir les
jeux en premier lieu
parce qu'ils ont reçu la légitimité
de la communauté internationale accordée
à  eux et le parti communiste chinois
en leur permettant d'accueillir les
jeux olympiques
[Musique]
vous